hi my name is Aishwarya nya and i'm
working with Professor dan fry in the
mechanical engineering department so
despite the fact that there's over 1
million people who use wheelchairs in
the developing world there's very little
data about the usage patterns so what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
instrument several different types of
wheelchairs with sensors in order to get
long-term usage patterns across
different countries so we're using
accelerometers or using strain gauges
we're using wheel wheel rotation sensors
all in combination with something called
the sense in which is being developed at
MIT it's a data acquisition system that
will broadcast our signals back to a
central server and what we're hoping to
do with this data is first get real-time
user results over a month on period in
January in Indonesia then take those
results analyze them and see whether
there are improvement we improvements we
can make on wheelchairs but also see
what type of usage is happening in
different countries hopefully we'll be
able to take this and then put it across
several different types of wheelchairs
from a standard Hospital chair to the
LFC which was developed at MIT and then
maybe even make recommendations to
different users based on what their
needs may be